pas mal
alors on a profité sans changer sont
chaudes un petit chat pour moutarde
s'il vous plaît un
nom parce qu'il ya la pluie et la
semoule la passion au sec
oui faut pas rester là vous nous ont
fait complètement dans la planche
moutarde ketchup
c'est pas la cible
s'entendait ce que je 1 c'est la fumée
qui m'a dérangé c'est me dérange pas
passé par là comme ça y'a pas de fumée
là vous êtes dans la boutique ça me
dérange il rigole pas avec vous un tel
boutique me rase pas devant le commerce
te plaît mais pourquoi c'est pas bien ce
que tu fait qu'on sait pas bien haut ce
podium mais si c'est bien regarder si
les merguez toute fraîche alors ça sent
pas bon les merguez se sont pas bons je
suis pas un marchand de bergessio blu
ray et ben voila j'ai acheter du pain
qu'est-ce que je vous mets du
ketchup et moutarde
nom promet larmes et la sueur le gris
personne n'a vu il est tombé par terre
non non non non non non ça ne veulent
pas me gâcher ma nourriture je suis bien
ici regardez la sortie de même que c'est
la meilleure place regardes tu fais pas
ça malheureux je sais pas ça malheureux
tu veux tu te fais pas le nom de la
boutique c'est pas ta boutique n'a pas
marqué ton nous
aller leur guette
qu'est ce que tu veux faire fuir les
clients c'est ça
allez on en profite on en profite
pendant que ses choix
et moi aussi j'ai de la mouillette à mr
gay
monde
qu'est ce que c'est que je sais du
candidat d'ici aux mêmes heures
ça vous comment bien marcher maintenant
je le regarde pas non non tu ne renverse
pas par terre arrête moi si on met du
ketchup sur ta chemise rouge ouais ouais
les chemises rouges ouais tiens allez
rouge maintenant je suis désolé c'est
parti tout seul si cependant non non non
non non non surtout pas avec la
nourriture tout seul c'est pas la
nourriture suis désolé voilà m'enverrait
votre note de teinturier a partout
laissez moi tranquille
regarde moi ça le boulot qui fait non
non non et où tu vois m6 au voleur au
voleur de merguez
[Musique]